There's a story my mom used to like to tell. My older sister Randi was eight or so when this happened. Something came up at school that Randi didn't understand, and she came home and she asked my mom, where do babies come from? And my mom just felt like, great. This is great. She's bringing this up on her own. I don't have to sit her down in some awkward birds and bees conversation someday. We can get this out of the way now, when she's young. And she's really excited to tell her this stuff.
我妈妈以前很喜欢讲一个故事。我姐姐兰迪发生这件事时大概八岁左右。在学校里遇到了一些兰迪不理解的事情，她回家问我妈妈：孩子是从哪儿来的？我妈妈当时心想，太好了，这真是太好了。她自己提出来了，我不用以后找个时间跟她进行那种尴尬的“鸟儿和蜜蜂”教育了。趁她还小，我们现在就可以把这事说清楚。她当时真的很兴奋能告诉她这些。
And she explains the whole thing, where babies come from, what sex is. And the way my mom always used to tell this story, she said that she felt like, I am doing such a good job here. I am such a good mom today. And at the end of it, she asked Randi, OK, so that's everything. Do you have any questions? And then Randi pauses for a long moment and she asks, can birds really fly?
于是她把所有事情都解释了一遍，孩子是怎么来的，什么是性。我妈妈过去讲这个故事时总是说，她当时觉得自己表现得太棒了。我今天真是个好妈妈。最后，她问兰迪：“好了，就是这些了，你还有什么问题吗？”兰迪沉默了很久，然后问道：“鸟儿真的会飞吗？”
And my mom realizes, of course, oh, she was not ready. She absorbed nothing. And sure enough, like a year passes and Randi comes back to her-- I don't remember why-- and asks her again, where do babies come from? And it's like the first time never happened. She remembered none of it.
我妈妈意识到，当然了，哦，她还没准备好。她什么也没听进去。果然，一年过去了，兰迪又来找她——我不记得为什么了——又问她：孩子是从哪儿来的？就好像第一次根本没发生过一样。她什么都不记得了。
And I think of that story sometimes when there are debates over what is suitable for children. An I think there's a whole category of things that kids protect themselves from, like they just don't want to engage with that stuff. Adults don't need to keep them from it. But then there's other stuff, stuff that does seep into their world that they take to heart and they mull about and they make part of themselves. And the thing that's difficult is that it can be really hard to predict what those things are going to be.
每当有人争论什么适合孩子时，我有时会想起那个故事。我认为有一大类事情是孩子们会自我保护不去接触的，他们就是不想参与那些事情。成年人不需要阻止他们。但还有其他一些事情，那些渗入他们世界的事情，他们会铭记在心，反复琢磨，并将其变成自己的一部分。困难之处在于，真的很难预测哪些事情会成为那样。
Today on our program, things that kids hear, things they see, things that happen to them that affect them in ways that they only understand later as adults. Like for instance, what it means to give little black kids toys that celebrate the Confederacy, or to drag teenage boys into the desert to watch atomic bombs go off, or to send kids who should be in elementary school over the border into the United States alone. How do you even quantify exactly what that does to a person? Well, today, we try to figure that out.
今天在我们的节目中，我们将讨论孩子们听到、看到以及发生在他们身上，并在他们成年后才明白其影响的事情。例如，给黑人小孩分发歌颂南方邦联的玩具意味着什么；把十几岁的男孩拖进沙漠观看原子弹爆炸意味着什么；或者把本该上小学的孩子独自送到美国边境意味着什么。你甚至该如何量化这对一个人造成的影响？好吧，今天我们试着弄清楚这一点。
From WBEZ Chicago, is This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》节目。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, Stars & Bars & Bars.
第一幕，星条与旗帜。
We got the idea for this week's show from this thing that happened to one of our producers, Neil Drumming, a realization that he came to in adulthood about a TV show that he'd watched as a kid. Here's Neil.
我们这周节目的灵感来源于我们的一位制作人尼尔·德拉明身上发生的一件事，这是他在成年后对自己小时候看的一部电视剧产生的顿悟。下面请听尼尔的讲述。
The hit TV show The Dukes of Hazzard ran from 1979 to 1985. It starred John Schneider and Tom Wopat as Bo and Luke Duke, to rakish good old boys trying to stay on the right side of the law in rural Georgia. But if you ask any man my age who was a fan of the show, The Dukes of Hazzard's true star was a bright orange 1969 Dodge Charger nicknamed the General Lee. Every week on CBS, the General Lee would roar through country backroads, leaping over virtually everything, defying the laws of physics, and blowing little boys' minds across America.
热门电视剧《杜克兄弟》于1979年至1985年播出。由约翰·施奈德和汤姆·沃帕特主演，饰演波·杜克和卢克·杜克，讲述了两个在佐治亚州农村试图守法的机灵好小伙的故事。但如果你问任何我这个年纪且是该剧粉丝的人，《杜克兄弟》真正的明星其实是一辆外号叫“李将军”的亮橙色1969年道奇战马。每周在CBS电视台，“李将军”都会在乡村小路上疾驰，飞越几乎所有障碍，无视物理定律，让全美国的男孩子们心潮澎湃。
I had a General Lee.
我曾有一个“李将军”玩具车。
In like a Matchbox or Hot Wheels?
是像火柴盒或风火轮那种吗？
No, I had a straight-up-- like the plastic joint.
不，我有一个纯正的，那种塑料材质的。
Oh, OK. Like a big-sized one.
哦，好的。那种大号的。
A big-sized one. You know, go around, drive on your dad's foot and he'd get angry. That size.
大号的。你知道，四处跑，从你爸爸脚上开过去，他会生气的那种尺寸。
This is one of my favorite rappers, Breeze Brewin. He's from the Bronx. Like me, he watched The Dukes of Hazzard faithfully as a boy. We both had Dukes of Hazzard lunchboxes. And we were both proud owners of miniature versions of the General Lee. Back then, it was probably one of the most coveted toys any kid in either of our neighborhoods could possess.
这是我最喜欢的说唱歌手之一，布里兹·布鲁因。他来自布朗克斯。和我一样，他小时候也是《杜克兄弟》的忠实观众。我们都有《杜克兄弟》的午餐盒。我们还都是微型版“李将军”的骄傲拥有者。在那时，这可能是我们两个社区里任何孩子都能拥有的最令人垂涎的玩具。
I remember the bully of the neighborhood stole mine and tried to pretend it was his.
我记得社区里的恶霸偷了我的，还试图假装那是他的。
I hate when that happens. This is mine, right? I'm like, no, it's definitely not.
我讨厌发生那种事。我说，这明明是我的，对吧？他说，不，绝对不是。
The General Lee was remarkable, not just because it was both fast and furious before that was a thing, but because its rooftop was emblazoned with the Confederate flag. As kids, black kids, pushing our mini American muscle along the carpets and concrete of New York City, neither Breeze nor I saw anything bothersome about that bold symbol up top. In fact, for us at the time, the rebel flag was just part of what made the car so damn cool.
“李将军”之所以引人注目，不仅因为它在那个概念流行之前就既快又猛，还因为它车顶上印着南方邦联的旗帜。作为黑人小孩，我们在纽约的各种地毯和水泥地上推着我们的微型美国肌肉车时，布里兹和我都没有觉得车顶上那个醒目的标志有什么不妥。事实上，对当时我们来说，叛军旗只是让这辆车变得无比酷的一部分。
There was a kid in my neighborhood, Irish kid. He had a orange Dodge Challenger 440, no flag on the top. I remember a lot of us were like, damn, he needs to throw the flag on top of that bad boy.
我住的社区里有个孩子，是个爱尔兰裔小孩。他有一辆橙色的道奇挑战者440，车顶上没有旗帜。我记得我们很多人都说，该死，他得在那辆酷车顶上加上那面旗子才行。
Wait. It was a real car or it was a toy?
等等。那是真车还是玩具？
No, he drove that bad boy. And you heard him coming down the block.
不，他开着那辆猛兽。你从街区就能听到他开过来的声音。
You were just like, that car would be dope.
你当时就觉得，那车要是这样会很酷。
That car would be dope if he had that flag on that bad boy.
要是他在那辆猛兽上加上那面旗子，那车会更酷。
I got the idea to talk to Breeze about this because, in 2001, as part of his group the Juggaknots, he wrote and released a song called "Generally." It's spelled like the adverb, but a play on the name of the Duke's prized racer. I don't remember exactly when I heard the song, but by then it'd been over 15 years since The Dukes of Hazzard went off the air. I hadn't thought about the show or the car in ages.
我想到要和布里兹谈谈这个，是因为在2001年，作为他的组合Juggaknots的一部分，他创作并发行了一首歌叫《Generally》。拼写和副词一样，但这是对《杜克兄弟》那辆珍贵赛车名字的文字游戏。我不记得确切是什么时候听到这首歌的，但那时距离《杜克兄弟》停播已经超过15年了。我很久没想过那部剧或那辆车了。
[MUSIC - "GENERALLY" BY THE JUGGAKNOTS]
[音乐 - JUGGAKNOTS的《GENERALLY》]
I'm pretty sure that when I was in my 20s and heard "Generally," well, that was the first time I put two and two together and realized, oh wait. One of my favorite toys growing up actually bore an unabashed affront to my humanity and freedom. The flag on the roof, how the hell did I miss that?
我很确定，当我20多岁听到《Generally》时，那是我第一次把这两件事联系在一起，意识到，等一下。我成长过程中最喜欢的玩具之一，竟然是对我的人格和自由的一种公然冒犯。车顶上的那面旗，我到底是怎么忽略它的？
Listening to the song again recently, I thought maybe it was about Breeze himself coming to that same realization. We are the same age, after all. But when he and I met to talk about it, Breeze said he'd recognize the inherent put-down in the General Lee's paint job by the time he was in high school. He was actually inspired to write "Generally" a few years later, after he'd had kids of his own.
最近重听这首歌，我以为这可能是关于布里兹自己有了同样的感悟。毕竟我们同岁。但当我和他见面谈论这件事时，布里兹说他在高中时就已经认识到“李将军”车身涂装中固有的贬低意味了。他实际上是在几年后，有了自己的孩子之后，才受到启发写了《Generally》。
One day, he took them on a shopping trip.
有一天，他带他们去购物。
I was literally in Toys "R" Us, probably on Gun Hill Road, near Co-op City, or the one in Yonkers, on Central Ave, and kids losing their shh, looking for toys and me questioning, like, what's up with these toys? And then I see the General Lee.
我当时真的在“玩具反斗城”，可能是在库普城附近的冈山路那家，或者是扬克斯中心大道那家。孩子们正在发疯找玩具，而我却在质疑：这些玩具到底是怎么回事？然后我看到了“李将军”。
The iconic roadster was back on the shelves, being pushed on a new generation to promote some TV movie relaunch.
那辆标志性的跑车又回到了货架上，为了宣传某部电视剧的重启版，被推销给新一代的孩子们。
Do you remember it?
你还记得它吗？
What, the song?
什么，这首歌？
Yeah.
对。
Yeah, definitely.
记得，当然。
Can you take me through it?
能带我回顾一下吗？
You want bars?
你想听歌词吗？
Yeah, man.
想啊，哥们。
Oh, man. It's tough. I'm 43. You're driving me batty. Daddy survive and be seeming slimmin' screaming women. Could the sound be more annoying?
哦，伙计。这很沉重。我43岁了。你让我抓狂。爸爸活着，看起来瘦弱，尖叫的女人。声音还能更烦人吗？
The thing I love about Breeze is that he writes these dense, clever, impressionistic rhymes that sound like words tumbling down stairs. In this first verse, he's telling the story of that trip to Toys "R" Us, building the scene of a frustrated parent overwhelmed by toys and demanding children.
我喜欢布里兹的一点是，他写了这些紧凑、聪明、意象派的歌词，听起来像单词从楼梯上滚落下来。在第一段里，他讲述了去“玩具反斗城”的那趟旅程，勾勒出一位被玩具和吵闹孩子搞得不知所措的父亲的场景。
Baggin' all these whack toys. Try to lack noise. Peace and quiet. Cease a riot constructively, then what I see, the General Lee.
把这些烂玩具都装袋。试图减少噪音。寻求和平与安静。建设性地平息骚乱，然后我看到了，“李将军”。
And I said, you know what? I need to explore this idea. Why did they think that was OK? Why did they think that they can show this image and make us champion that image? Why is it OK to make our pain this pop icon? Why was it OK? I just wanted to attack it, that you would have the audacity to do that. I was just thinking, not with my kids.
我说，你知道吗？我需要探讨这个想法。他们为什么认为这是可以的？他们为什么认为可以展示这种形象并让我们去支持它？为什么把我们的痛苦变成流行偶像没关系？为什么没关系？我只想攻击这一点，因为他们竟然有胆量这样做。我当时就在想，绝不能让我孩子碰到。
So then there's the chorus after that, right?
然后后面有副歌，对吧？
Yeah. So the chorus is like, the General Lee, representin' for your clan. The General Lee, for real, somebody pulled a fast one. The General Lee, now I'm starting to overstand. The General Lee wasn't the first. Won't be the last one.
对。副歌是：李将军，代表你的氏族。李将军，说真的，有人耍了花招。李将军，现在我开始看透了。李将军不是第一个。也不会是最后一个。
I love that line, "Somebody pulled a fast one," just because it's nice. It's like, the car is fast. It's a really nice line.
我喜欢“有人耍了花招”这句，因为它很精妙。车很快，这真是个绝妙的句子。
I appreciate that.
我很感激你的评价。
That's very slick.
那非常精明。
I mean, it's pretty blatant. It's the hoodwinking. They got over, you know? They normalized it, for better or for worse. It's a huge screw you. It's like, we're going to do this. You're not going to say nothing. We're going to put it on prime time TV. We're going to put it in Toys "R" Us. In fact, you're going to buy it. In the song, I say, "But sell my L. Sell my loss."
我是说，这相当露骨。这就是欺骗。他们得逞了，你懂吗？无论好坏，他们把这一切正常化了。这是一记响亮的耳光。就像是，我们要这么做，而你什么都不会说。我们要把它放在黄金时段电视上。我们要把它放在玩具反斗城。事实上，你还会买它。在歌里，我写道：“但卖掉我的L，卖掉我的损失。”
Of course, at seven, eight, nine years old, it wasn't Breeze and I controlling the TV remote or spending our hard-earned cash. It was ultimately our parents who let us watch the show and bought us the toys. Considering that both of my parents were born and raised in rural South Carolina and experienced chilling racism firsthand, you'd think they would have objected to the Dukes and their General Lee. But they didn't.
当然，在七八九岁的时候，控制电视遥控器或花掉我们辛苦赚来的钱的不是布里兹和我。最终是我们的父母让我们看那部剧，并给我们买了那些玩具。考虑到我的父母都是在南卡罗来纳州农村出生长大的，并亲身经历过令人心寒的种族歧视，你本以为他们会反对“杜克兄弟”和他们的“李将军”。但他们没有。
Breeze's parents, who are from the Caribbean, they didn't either. He has a theory as to what our parents were thinking.
布里兹的父母来自加勒比海，他们也没有。对于我们父母当时的想法，他有一个理论。
I think it's a lot about, I don't want my kids to be left out. I don't want my kids to be weird. It was a number-one show. So it was like, why deny them that?
我觉得这很大程度上是因为，我不想让我的孩子被排挤。我不想让我的孩子显得怪异。那是收视率第一的节目。所以他们觉得，为什么要拒绝他们呢？
OK. This is important. On TV, the doors on the General Lee were welded shut, as is common with a lot of stock race cars. So Bo and Luke Duke were constantly hopping through the windows. It was the only way in or out of the car. Here's Breeze with the song's final verse.
好的。这一点很重要。在电视上，“李将军”的车门是被焊死的，这在很多库存赛车中很常见。所以波和卢克·杜克总是从车窗跳进跳出。那是进出这辆车的唯一途径。下面是布里兹带来的最后一小节。
Disturbable to see what we was murdered to when it coulda, shoulda been a convertible. I started off with like, you know what? You's constantly jumping in and out of the windows. It would have made more sense and been more practical to have been a convertible. Just cut the top off. Chop the top off. But you needed it. You needed the top of the car. You needed to show that image because that's the pimpery. That's the game. I get it. Y'all wanted to see it. Here it is.
看到我们被谋杀的东西本可以是敞篷车，这让人心烦。我开始想，你知道吗？你们不停地从窗户跳进跳出。如果它是敞篷车会更有意义，也更实际。只要把顶棚切掉。砍掉车顶。但你需要它。你需要车顶。你需要展示那种形象，因为那是皮条客行径。那是游戏规则。我明白了。你们想看，那给你吧。
OK. Take me through that verse.
好的。带我解读一下那一节。
Disturbable to see what we was murdered to when it coulda, shoulda been a convertible. See that they're climbin' through the windows and go make better time and do the pro hoppin', but no stopping commercial use. The issue, they get you with decals. Match the lunchbox, pajamas. You wanna snatch the bunch. Lock that be wild, generally praise the stuff, crave the stuff, slaves to stuff. Get it for me, begging like, please.
看到我们被谋杀的东西本可以是敞篷车，这让人心烦。看看他们爬过窗户，本可以节省时间并做得更好，但不停地商业使用。问题是，他们用贴纸抓住你。搭配午餐盒、睡衣。你想把它们一网打尽。锁住那个野蛮人，盲目崇拜这些东西，渴望这些东西，沦为物质的奴隶。给我买这个，乞求着说，求求你。
So now, with that, I talked about how I would beg my parents for it. But then it's just like sporting the pain. You know what I mean? Like, you were sporting my pain and it's literally a comedy. Sportin' the pain. Sure was a brainwashed kid, but never had a fad with rockin' a swastika. Of course, Nazi. But that I'd rather not see. The closest that I got be [INAUDIBLE] Haile Selassie. But sell my L, see it's nothing than this double standard. Trouble, be it something candid or this subtle. Gun the flag down. What? No hesitatin'. Gutter regulation. [BLEEP] the legislation. But now some of y'all walking around like, for shame, word, as I wonder what the murderers of James Byrd thought about the General Lee.
现在，就这些，我谈到了我会如何恳求父母给我买。但这就像是在展示痛苦。你懂我的意思吗？就像是，你在展示我的痛苦，而这竟然是一部喜剧。展示痛苦。我当然是个被洗脑的孩子，但从来没有对佩戴纳粹万字旗产生过狂热。当然，纳粹。但那是我宁愿不看到的。我所接触到的最近似的是海尔·塞拉西。但卖掉我的L，你看这除了双重标准什么都没有。麻烦，无论是坦率还是微妙。枪击那面旗帜。什么？毫不犹豫。排水沟管制。操那些立法。但现在有些人走来走去，好像在说，“真丢脸，真的”，我在想詹姆斯·伯德的凶手会怎么看待“李将军”。
In 1998, James Byrd, a black man in Texas, was badly beaten and pissed on by three white supremacists. The men then chained Byrd by his ankles to a pickup truck and dragged him over asphalt for roughly three miles. Byrd died when his head and arm were severed from his body. The white supremacists, who sported various Nazi and Confederate symbols, dumped Byrd's mutilated body near a black church. This atrocity was heavy on Breeze's mind when he wrote "Generally," which is why the last verse ends in anger. As he says, "Gun the flag down. No hesitating."
1998年，德克萨斯州的一名黑人男子詹姆斯·伯德被三名白人至上主义者残忍殴打并撒尿。这些人随后用铁链将伯德的脚踝拴在一辆皮卡车上，在柏油路上拖行了大约三英里。伯德因头部和手臂从身上断裂而死亡。这些身穿各种纳粹和南方邦联标志的白人至上主义者，将伯德残缺不全的尸体丢弃在一家黑人教堂附近。布里兹在创作《Generally》时，这起暴行沉重地压在他的心头，这就是为什么最后一节以愤怒收尾。正如他所说，“枪击那面旗帜。毫不犹豫。”
I kind of was like, I know some people are going to be like, Breeze, you're wilin'. You're talking about shooting down a flag. You should go through the right channels. There's legislation.
我当时有点像是觉得，我知道有些人会说，布里兹，你疯了。你在谈论射击一面旗帜。你应该通过正当渠道。有立法。
But I'm like, word, well, what do the murderers of James Byrd think about the General Lee? You know what I mean? It's just like, at some point, we gotta kill your idols. We gotta burn your idols.
但我说，真的，好吧，詹姆斯·伯德的凶手会怎么看“李将军”？你懂我的意思吗？这就像是，在某个时刻，我们必须杀死你们的偶像。我们必须烧毁你们的偶像。
So you told me that you've been thinking about this song a lot lately.
所以你告诉我你最近一直在思考这首歌。
Literally, like a week before you called, I was listening to the song and I almost got a little choked up. Because, like, god damn, you know what I mean? It's like, 16 years later, why is it still an issue? I'd like to think, come on. You're better than that now, America.
就在你给我打电话前一周，我还在听这首歌，我差点哽咽了。因为，该死，你懂吗？这就像是，16年后，为什么这还是个问题？我希望能想到，得了吧。美国，你现在应该表现得更好一些。
[LAUGHING]
[笑声]
That said, I can't help but harbor a little bit of nostalgia for the General Lee. Not so much for the thing itself, but for what it represents for me, a time before I could possibly recognize the insidiousness of its design, before I really understood its origins or how that history has shaped me and the people I care about, back when all I really had to worry about was who had the coolest toy on the block.
话虽如此，我还是忍不住对“李将军”产生了一点怀旧之情。不是对那个事物本身，而是因为它对我所代表的意义：一个在我还不可能认出其设计阴险性之前的时光，在我真正理解其起源，或这段历史如何塑造了我及我在乎的人们之前，那时候我唯一需要担心的就是街区里谁有最酷的玩具。
Neil Drumming is one of the producers of our program.
尼尔·德拉明是我们节目的制作人之一。
I honestly believe they should've changed the name Robert E. Lee High School a very long time ago, probably after, you know, '90s, early 2000s.
我真心认为他们早就该改掉罗伯特·李高中这个名字了，大概在90年代或2000年初的时候。
That's Joralen Maulbin. She's 16, a member of the drill team at Robert E. Lee High School in Tyler, Texas. A black girl with a blonde Afro, which, last Friday, was tucked under a white cowgirl hat, part of her drill team uniform. She talked to our producer B.A. Parker.
那是乔拉伦·莫尔宾。她16岁，是德克萨斯州泰勒市罗伯特·李高中的仪仗队成员。一个留着金发爆炸头的黑人女孩，上周五，那头卷发被塞进了一顶白色牛仔帽里，那是她仪仗队制服的一部分。她和我们的制作人B.A.帕克谈过。
I love being on this team. I love the girls who are on here. But you know, the history is still there at the back of my mind, and I know a lot of it doesn't really bother that many people. But it's still something that I find that gets to me.
我热爱这个团队。我爱这里的女孩们。但你知道，历史仍然存在于我的脑海深处，我知道很多事情并不真正困扰那么多人。但这仍然是我发现会让我难受的事情。
That history is that Robert E. Lee High School was founded in 1958, four years after Brown vs. Board of Education as a place for white students to go to avoid integration. The town gave it the name Robert E. Lee as a way to give the finger to the civil rights movement. The school prided itself on having this massive Confederate flag, allegedly the second largest Confederate flag in the world. It took 20 people to carry it.
那段历史是罗伯特·李高中成立于1958年，在《布朗诉教育委员会案》之后四年，作为白人学生为避免种族融合而设立的地方。镇上给它取名“罗伯特·李”，是为了向民权运动竖中指。学校以拥有这面巨大的南方邦联旗为荣，据称是世界上第二大的南方邦联旗。需要20个人才能抬动它。
Then in the 1970s, the courts ordered the town to integrate the high school. These days, 60% of the school was black and Latino, though in Tyler, it is still referred to as the white high school. When they announce the name of the school at the beginning of games, Joralen says she just kind of blocks it out. She found out about the school's history a little while ago.
到了20世纪70年代，法院下令该镇对高中进行种族融合。如今，学校里60%是黑人和拉丁裔，尽管在泰勒，它仍然被称为“白人高中”。当比赛开始时播报学校的名字，乔拉伦说她就直接选择屏蔽掉。她前不久才发现学校的这段历史。
I learned this last year, I believe, because we have memory books, and it dates back all the way to when Lee first opened. We were flipping through one of the very first ones and that was when I saw the uniforms and all the traditions that they used to have. The Southern Belle Drill Team and our Belle Guards, they were called the Rebels and the Rebelettes, and they did wear confederate uniform style clothing and things like that. And they proudly displayed their confederate flag. And it just shocked me. And all I could think about was, what? Like, for real? Y'all are kidding me right now.
我想是去年才知道的，因为我们有纪念册，可以追溯到李高中刚开学的时候。我们在翻阅其中最早的一本时，那是我第一次看到他们的制服和他们过去拥有的所有传统。南方佳丽仪仗队和我们的佳丽卫队，他们被称为叛军和叛军小妞，他们确实穿着南方邦联制服风格的衣服之类的东西。他们自豪地展示他们的南方邦联旗。这让我感到震惊。我当时脑子里只想的是，什么？真的吗？你们现在是在跟我开玩笑吧。
Do you have to sing the school song?
你必须唱校歌吗？
They try to make us learn it, but I never memorized it.
他们试图让我们学习它，但我从来没背下来过。
The school song starts with the lyrics, "Robert E. Lee, we raise our voices in praise of your name. May honor and glory e'er guide you to fame."
校歌的第一句歌词是：“罗伯特·李，我们高声赞美你的名字。愿荣誉和荣耀永远引导你走向名声。”
Have you ever looked at the lyrics of it?
你看过歌词吗？
I've looked at the lyrics, which is why I haven't tried to memorize it.
我看过歌词，这就是为什么我没有试图背诵它。
Would you ever sing it?
你以后会唱吗？
Never in my life. Never.
这辈子都不会。绝不。
There's one lyric in the school song, "Our memories will bind us to Robert E. Lee." That part definitely seems true.
校歌里有一句歌词，“我们的记忆将把我们与罗伯特·李联系在一起。”那部分确实看起来是真的。
[DRUMMING]
[鼓声]
[MUSIC - "WAITING FOR THE ROBERT E. LEE" BY DEAN MARTIN]
[音乐 - 迪恩·马丁的《等待罗伯特·李》]
Act Two, History is Not a Toy.
第二幕，历史不是玩具。
So there are over 100 public schools around the country named after white Confederate heroes and over 700 monuments and statues memorializing the Confederacy in public places. Those numbers come from a survey done in 2016 by the Southern Poverty Law Center. But as people have noted in the last few months, with all this commemoration of the white experience of life in the South before and during the Civil War, there's not that much out there memorializing the black experience. One of the few places is in Baltimore.
全国有100多所公立学校以白人南方邦联英雄命名，公共场所还有700多座纪念南方邦联的纪念碑和雕像。这些数字来自南方贫困法律中心2016年的一项调查。但正如人们在过去几个月里指出的那样，随着对美国内战前和内战期间南方白人生活经验的这种种纪念，却几乎没有什么纪念黑人经验的场所。巴尔的摩是为数不多的地方之一。
I was surprised to learn it was there. I grew up in Baltimore. And OK, this place came into existence after I moved away, but I am back in Baltimore regularly to see family. And Baltimore is segregated enough that I never heard of it till B.A. Parker, our producer who also grew up in Baltimore, told me about it. Here she is.
我很惊讶地发现它就在那里。我在巴尔的摩长大。好吧，这个地方是在我搬走之后才出现的，但我经常回到巴尔的摩看望家人。而且巴尔的摩的种族隔离足够严重，直到我们的制作人B.A.帕克（她也在巴尔的摩长大）告诉我之前，我从未听说过它。下面请听她的讲述。
Every black kid in Baltimore knows this place. Most of us went there on field trips when we were in school or were taken there by an earnest parent. It's called the National Great Blacks in Wax Museum. That's great blacks, and they're rendered in wax. It's the first black history wax museum in the country. I first went there on a field trip in the third grade. And for better or worse, it's been stuck in my memory ever since. To be honest, it scared the [BLEEP] out of me. It's violent and graphic and unlike any other museum I've ever been to. And its main clientele was children.
巴尔的摩的每个黑人孩子都知道这个地方。我们大多数人在上学时去那里参加过实地考察，或者被尽责的家长带去过。它叫“国家伟大黑人蜡像馆”。那是“伟大的黑人”，他们被塑造成蜡像。这是全国第一个黑人历史蜡像馆。我第一次去是在三年级实地考察时。无论好坏，从那以后它就一直留在我的记忆里。说实话，它吓坏我了。它既暴力又生动，不像我见过的任何其他博物馆。而它的主要受众是儿童。
Even today, I can talk to anybody who grew up black and in Baltimore, and if you bring up the Blacks in Wax, they'll be like, yeah, that was messed up, right? Texting with friends and family about this last week, I got messages like, "I had nightmares," and "I started to tear up," and "I can still see it in my head." I wanted to go back to the museum to see if it was as bad as I remembered.
即使在今天，我可以和任何在巴尔的摩长大的黑人交谈，如果你提到黑人蜡像馆，他们会说，是的，那很糟糕，对吧？上周和朋友家人发短信讨论这件事时，我收到了这样的信息：“我做过噩梦”，“我当时想哭”，“我现在脑子里还能看到那些场景”。我想回到博物馆看看，它是否真的像我记忆中那么糟糕。
There's a crowd of people from a bus coming in.
有一群从巴士下来的人正在进来。
There's a couple of kids.
有几个孩子。
So I went back there recently with my colleague, Sean Cole. The museum itself is an old fire station and three row houses fused into one building. In the lobby, the wax figures of W.E.B Du Bois and Carter G. Woodson are there to greet you. Next to the ticket booth is a figure of the great military general Hannibal riding a massive elephant, and up overhead is the first black female pilot, Bessie Coleman.
所以我最近和我的同事肖恩·科尔一起回到了那里。博物馆本身是一个老消防站和三栋排屋合并成的一栋建筑。在大厅里，W.E.B·杜波依斯和卡特·G·伍德森的蜡像在那里迎接你。售票亭旁边是伟大的军事统帅汉尼拔骑着巨大大象的雕像，头顶上是第一位黑人女性飞行员贝西·科尔曼。
Oh, I didn't even see there's an airplane above us.
哦，我甚至没看到我们上面还有一架飞机。
There is an airplane above us with a cool chick in it with her shades on, and she's taking no one's mess.
我们头顶上确实有一架飞机，里面坐着一个戴着墨镜的酷女孩，她谁的账都不买。
The lobby's all inspiring and stuff, but then you buy your ticket and actually enter the museum. Then everything changes. A quick warning. There's a lot of violence of all sorts in what follows. It might not be for everyone.
大厅里充满启发性，但当你买了票真正进入博物馆时，一切都变了。快速提醒一下。接下来的内容中包含各种各样的暴力，可能不适合所有人。
When you step inside the museum, it's dark. Immediately to the right, there's a wax figure of a slave. He's on his knees, his teeth knocked out, and he's being held down by two white slavers who pull his head back. They've shoved a long funnel into his mouth and are pouring gruel through it, force-feeding him. Brown gruel spills out of his mouth. As an act of rebellion, some slaves wouldn't eat, so the slavers made them. This is the very first thing you see.
当你走进博物馆时，里面很暗。右边立刻是一个奴隶的蜡像。他跪在地上，牙齿被打掉了，被两个白人奴隶主按住头部向后仰。他们往他嘴里塞进一个长漏斗，正通过它灌下稀粥，强迫他进食。棕色的稀粥从他嘴里流出来。作为一种反抗行为，一些奴隶拒绝进食，所以奴隶主强迫他们吃。这是你进门第一眼看到的东西。
And then to the left is one of the museum's signature attractions.
然后在左边是博物馆最著名的展品之一。
All right. So do you want to go into the slave ship?
好了。你想去奴隶船里看看吗？
They've built a facsimile of a slave ship into the museum. It's not that big, about the size of a large trailer, but when I was eight, it seemed enormous. Back then, walking down to the hold below was like walking onto an amusement park ride, only the opposite of fun.
他们在博物馆里建造了一个奴隶船的复制品。它并不大，大约只有一辆大拖车那么大，但当我八岁时，它看起来巨大无比。那时候，走到下面的船舱就像走进一个游乐园游乐设施，只是与乐趣恰恰相反。
At the entrance, there are two white wax slave merchants, both impeccably dressed. One sits behind a desk. It used to be that, when you stepped onto the stairs, a recording would play, one of the merchants announcing, "New load of slaves coming aboard now." At eight, I understood. They meant me. I was supposed to be a new slave. I burst into tears. At first, I refused to go all the way down into the ship. But the other kids did it, so I did it, too.
在入口处，有两个穿着无可挑剔的白人蜡像奴隶商人。一个坐在桌子后面。过去，当你踏上楼梯时，会播放一段录音，其中一个商人宣布：“新一批奴隶现在登船。”八岁时，我听懂了。他们指的是我。我本该是一个新的奴隶。我当场大哭起来。起初，我拒绝一直走到船舱下面。但其他孩子都进去了，所以我也进去了。
And what I saw when I got to the bottom of the steps was what I was seeing now. Another vicious-looking white man.
当我走到台阶底部时，我看到的正是我现在看到的。另一个长相恶毒的白人男人。
And he's branding a slave woman who has a chain around her neck and placing the brand on her shoulder. And she's fully nude and covered in blood. Jeez. It's just pure agony's on her face, and he looks like he's full of hate and anger and is just ready to torture someone. None of this has changed.
他正在给一个脖子上套着锁链的奴隶妇女打烙印，正把烙印放在她的肩膀上。她全身赤裸，浑身是血。天哪。她脸上全是纯粹的痛苦，而他看起来充满了仇恨和愤怒，准备折磨任何人。这些都没有变。
There's collections on shelves of just parts of bodies bloodied.
架子上有成堆的布满血迹的身体部位收藏。
Being eaten by rats. That should be noted. There's one below that's dismembered and being eaten by rats.
被老鼠吃掉。这应该说明一下。下面有一个被肢解并被老鼠吃掉的。
The museum goes for an intense realism. It doesn't leave anything out. It's over the top in a way that's almost campy. This is probably because the wax figures all were made in the 1970s.
博物馆追求强烈的写实感。它什么都没有遗漏。它以一种几乎荒诞的方式夸张。这可能是因为所有的蜡像都是20世纪70年代制作的。
The slavers have mutton chops. A few of the slaves look more like they're from Good Times than from Roots. But the scenes are always based on documented atrocities.
奴隶主留着羊排鬓角。一些奴隶看起来更像是来自《好时光》而不是《根》。但场景总是基于有据可查的暴行。
At a certain point in the slave ship, I turn around and I see that the entire wall behind me is one huge mirror. And then I see the chained-up slaves and I'm forced to look at myself, and it comes home to me in an instant that these people are my ancestors. Without the torture, without the sorrow, without the misery that they endured during the Middle Passage, there would be no me.
在奴隶船的某个地方，我转过身，看到身后的整面墙是一面巨大的镜子。然后我看到了被锁链锁住的奴隶，我被迫看着自己，我立刻意识到这些人是我的祖先。如果没有折磨，没有悲伤，没有他们在“中段航程”中忍受的痛苦，就不会有我。
So what do you remember from when you were a kid and seeing this?
那么你小时候看到这些还记得什么？
I remember being confused and being scared. The fact that it's someone who's my skin, my-- you don't have the language for it, but it is a pause and reflect. And your eyes grow wide, and you're trying to understand what it means. I'm sorry. I just got distracted by them trying to shove the guy in the oven. Sorry.
我记得感到困惑和害怕。事实上，那是跟我肤色一样的人，我的……你没有词汇来描述它，但这是一种暂停和反思。你的眼睛睁大，试图理解它意味着什么。对不起。我被他们试图把那个家伙塞进烤箱里的场景分散了注意力。抱歉。
What? What?
什么？什么？
No, that's the Underground Railroad. That's a fake oven.
不，那是地下铁路。那是一个假烤箱。
Oh, OK.
哦，好的。
There was an exhibit behind Sean of a white man helping this runaway slave escape through an oven with a door in the back, allowing him to slip through from one house to another and another. As a kid, it wasn't like I was unfamiliar with black history. By the third grade, I'd already been to the plantation in North Carolina where my ancestors were sold. I was obsessed with Thurgood Marshall. I wanted to be him. I wanted to marry him. Everything.
肖恩身后有一个展品，是一个白人帮助逃亡的奴隶通过一个后面有门的烤箱逃脱，让他能从一个房子滑向另一个房子，再一个。作为一个孩子，我并非不了解黑人历史。到三年级时，我已经去过北卡罗来纳州的种植园，我祖先被卖掉的地方。我痴迷于瑟古德·马歇尔。我想成为他。我想嫁给他。一切都是。
And my elementary school made such a big deal about Martin Luther King every year. And I once got to play one of Coretta Scott King's bridesmaids in an assembly. But it was exactly that, the elementary school version of black history-- Dr. King, Nelson Mandela, Rosa Parks, the coloring book of greatest hits, not the brutal reality.
我们小学每年对马丁·路德·金非常重视。我曾经在一次集会上扮演过科瑞塔·斯科特·金的一名伴娘。但那正是所谓的黑人历史的小学版本——金博士、纳尔逊·曼德拉、罗莎·帕克斯，那种涂色书式的精选集，而不是残酷的现实。
But none of this compares to what you see in the museum's basement. The basement is so intense that the museum has posted a sign outside of it warning that you shouldn't go into it until you're at least 12. Under 16, you need a chaperone. We headed there, past Henry Box Brown, the slave who mailed himself to freedom in a box. When I was a kid, he'd pop out and wave but it startled too many kids and they don't do that anymore. We walked past Henry to the top of the basement stairs.
但这些都比不上你在博物馆地下室看到的东西。地下室太激烈了，博物馆在外面贴了一个标志，警告你在12岁之前不应该进去。16岁以下需要监护人陪同。我们往那边走，经过亨利·箱子·布朗，那个把自己装进盒子里邮寄去自由的奴隶。我小时候，他会跳出来招手，但那吓坏了太多的孩子，他们现在不那样做了。我们经过亨利来到地下室楼梯的顶部。
All right. So we're going to go downstairs to the lynching exhibit.
好了。我们要下楼去看看私刑展区。
I didn't see the lynching exhibit when I was eight. I saw it on a second field trip when I was a freshman in high school. I still don't think I was ready. I don't think I was ready now.
我八岁时没看过私刑展。我是在高中一年级第二次实地考察时看到的。我仍然认为我还没准备好。我觉得我现在也没准备好。
It starts off when you're still walking down the stairs, with historical photos and newspaper clippings of actual lynchings as recent as 1998. Black people hanging from trees, set on fire, dragged by trucks. Photos of the dead surrounded by crowds of white spectators all decked out in their Sunday best, smiling little girls with ribbons in their hair looking at the camera, some with pride, a man hanging from a tree behind them. Then at the bottom of the stairs, as soon as you round the corner.
当你走下楼梯时，它就开始了，展示着真实私刑的照片和报纸剪报，最近的甚至到1998年。黑人从树上吊下来，被点火焚烧，被卡车拖行。死者周围聚集着大批白人观众，他们穿着周日的最好礼服，扎着发带的小女孩微笑着对着镜头，有些人带着骄傲，身后吊着一个男人。然后在楼梯底部，一转弯。
All right. So.
好了。
Oh, boy.
哦，天哪。
Yeah.
是的。
Ohh.
哦。
Um. Do you want me to descr--
嗯。你想让我描……
Oh, my god.
哦，我的上帝。
Do you want me to describe what's happening here?
你想让我描述这里发生了什么吗？
In front of us was a husband and wife named Hayes and Mary Turner. They lived in Georgia. Back in 1918, a local black man had killed a plantation owner. And when the sheriff's office went hunting for the killer, they and a mob lynched practically every other black man in their path. Hayes Turner was one of the casualties in that massacre. A warning, this gets especially graphic.
在我们面前的是一对名叫海耶斯和玛丽·特纳的夫妻。他们住在佐治亚州。1918年，当地一名黑人杀害了一名种植园主。当治安官办公室去追捕凶手时，他们和一群暴徒几乎私刑处死了沿途遇到的每一个黑人男性。海耶斯·特纳是那场大屠杀的受害者之一。警告，这特别生动。
Just as I was about to describe what happened next to Sean, the museum's educator, Imani Haynes, walked in, and I was grateful she did because she took over.
就在我准备向肖恩描述接下来发生的事情时，博物馆的教育家伊马尼·海恩斯走了进来，我很感激她，因为她接过了话。
He had nothing to do with the situation, and unfortunately he was lynched. Afterwards, he was castrated. So what you're seeing in this scene in the exhibit is Turner lynched. He is wearing overalls. And we have his overalls opened up in his private region, blood dripping down.
他与这件事毫无关系，但不幸的是他被私刑处死了。之后，他被阉割了。所以你在这个展区的场景中看到的是被吊死的特纳。他穿着工装裤。我们把他的工装裤在他的私密部位打开，血流如注。
Next to Hayes is his wife, Mary. After he was lynched, Mary bravely went seeking justice for her husband. She was eight months pregnant at the time. They lynched her, too.
海耶斯旁边是他的妻子玛丽。在他被私刑处死后，玛丽勇敢地去为丈夫寻求正义。她当时怀有八个月的身孕。他们也私刑处死了她。
In the museum exhibit, she's hanging from the neck, but in real life, they actually hanged her by her feet, set her on fire, sliced her stomach open, and pulled out her baby, which was still alive. That's what's depicted in wax. Then they stomped on its head.
在博物馆的展览中，她是吊在脖子上的，但在现实生活中，他们实际上是把她双脚吊起来，点火焚烧，剖开她的肚子，拉出了她的婴儿，婴儿当时还活着。这就是蜡像所描绘的。然后他们踩碎了婴儿的头。
The sign on the wall adds to the story that haunted me. It's also the only part that historians can't fully verify. It reads, "Walter White, describing the lynching of Mary Turner and her husband Hayes Turner, depicted in this scene, said that it was too horrible to describe the mob taking the time to sew two cats in Mrs. Turner's stomach and making bets as to which one would climb out first."
墙上的标志增添了那个困扰我的故事。这也是历史学家无法完全核实的部分。上面写着：“沃尔特·怀特在描述玛丽·特纳和她的丈夫海耶斯·特纳的私刑场景时说，那太可怕了，无法形容，暴徒甚至有时间把两只猫缝进特纳夫人的肚子里，并打赌哪一只会先爬出来。”
To the left of the Turners' bodies is a mantelpiece with souvenir jars. Sometimes the lynchers would keep pieces of their victims. In these jars were supposed to be the ears, locks of hair, and genitalia of black people, all next to a kid's baseball trophy. I'm not sure why that's there except to underscore the point that these body parts are trophies, too. It's a difficult room to process.
特纳夫妇尸体的左边是一个壁炉架，上面放着纪念品罐。有时私刑者会保留受害者的身体部位。这些罐子里本应装着黑人的耳朵、头发和生殖器，旁边是一个孩子的棒球奖杯。我不确定那为什么放在那儿，除了为了强调这些身体部位也是战利品。这是一个很难消化的房间。
When I saw this at 14, some of my classmates didn't even know how to react. A few of them stoic, others awkwardly deflecting with, yo. I remember feeling angry because you couldn't escape it. There are signs around the room that anticipate your distress. They say, "Identify with the victims and martyrs and never forget them. But do not get bitter or despondent over what they endured."
14岁时看到这个，我的一些同学甚至不知道该如何反应。他们中有的人表现得不动声色，有的则尴尬地回避着说，“哟”。我记得当时感到愤怒，因为你无法逃避。房间周围的标志预料到了你的痛苦。它们说：“认同受害者和烈士，永远不要忘记他们。但不要因为他们所忍受的一切而变得苦毒或绝望。”
Dr. Joanne Martin founded the museum with her husband Elmer in 1983, and when I told her all the kids in my third grade were crying and freaking out and holding hands, she was fully aware that happens. In fact, it's intentional.
乔安妮·马丁博士和她的丈夫埃尔默于1983年创立了这家博物馆，当我告诉她我三年级的所有孩子都在哭泣、惊慌失措、牵着手时，她完全知道那是怎么回事。事实上，这是故意的。
For me, that's the point. When they leave shaken, when they leave crying-- and that's often the reaction-- I have no problem with those tears. What people are going to talk about years later is going to be our slave ship. And they are going to say, I never forgot your lynching exhibit.
对我来说，这就是重点。当他们颤抖着离开，当他们哭着离开时——这通常是他们的反应——我一点也不介意那些眼泪。多年后人们会谈论的将是我们的奴隶船。他们会说，我永远忘不了你的私刑展。
And everything else, it seems like a movie, if you don't have a sense of exactly what people were fighting against. If you think that Rosa Parks, that what she did had something to do with the seat on the bus and you don't understand that that act was going to get her jailed, but it could have gotten her lynched, as well.
如果一个人不知道人们到底是在对抗什么，那么其他的一切看起来都像是一场电影。如果你认为罗莎·帕克斯在巴士上的座位仅仅是关于那个座位，而你不理解那个举动会让她入狱，也可能让她被私刑处死。
When Joanne and her husband founded the museum, they set out to create something they wished existed in the world, a museum that celebrated and preserved black history, created by black people for black people in a majority black city. They were professors at historically black universities in Baltimore, Elmer at Morgan State and Joanne at Coppin. But they wanted to reach more than just the academic class.
当乔安妮和她的丈夫创办博物馆时，他们旨在创造他们希望世界上存在的东西，一个庆祝和保护黑人历史的博物馆，由黑人为黑人在一个以黑人为主的城市中创建。他们是巴尔的摩历史悠久的黑人大学的教授，埃尔默在摩根州立大学，乔安妮在科平州立大学。但他们想触及的不仅仅是学术阶层。
When they visited a wax museum in St. Augustine, Florida, they thought, yeah, wax figures. That's the way to go. They had money saved for a house but instead put it towards wax figures. It still wasn't enough. Wax figures are absurdly expensive-- $4,500 then, but tens of thousands of dollars now. They ended up with their first four black history figures-- Frederick Douglass, John Brown, Nat Turner, and Mary McLeod Bethune.
当他们参观佛罗里达州圣奥古斯丁的一家蜡像馆时，他们想，是的，蜡像。就该这么办。他们为买房攒了钱，但取而代之把钱投入到了蜡像中。那仍然不够。蜡像非常昂贵——当时是4500美元，现在则是几万美元。他们最终拥有了最初的四个黑人历史人物——弗雷德里克·道格拉斯、约翰·布朗、纳特·特纳和玛丽·麦克劳德·白求恩。
Elmer and Joanne would tour around with their quartet of wax figures at different schools, in churches, and expos.
埃尔默和乔安妮会带着他们的四人蜡像组合在不同的学校、教堂和博览会上巡回展示。
We just would take the figures, set them up as exhibits, throw them into my Pontiac, take them back home to our two bedroom apartment. And so if you looked into the guest bedroom of our two bedroom apartment, you would have found Mary McLeod Bethune's head on the dresser and Frederick Douglass' parts over in a corner and so forth. And I just gave him an ultimatum. Mary McLeod Bethune has got to go. You've got to find a place for Mary McLeod Bethune.
我们只是带上这些人物，布置成展品，把它们扔进我的庞蒂亚克车里，带回我们两居室的公寓。所以如果你往我们两居室公寓的客房看，你会发现梳妆台上放着玛丽·麦克劳德·白求恩的头，角落里放着弗雷德里克·道格拉斯的肢体等等。我给了他最后通牒。玛丽·麦克劳德·白求恩必须得走。你必须给玛丽·麦克劳德·白求恩找个地方。
Dr. Martin told me they're thinking of expanding the museum and making it more child-friendly, toning down the violence. Which surprised me. It doesn't seem like her mission at all, and it would only make sense if our history were a little more child-friendly, which it definitely isn't.
马丁博士告诉我，他们正在考虑扩建博物馆并使其对儿童更友好，淡化暴力。这让我很惊讶。这看起来根本不像是她的使命，而且只有在我们的历史稍微对儿童友好一点的时候才说得通，显然事实并非如此。
The four little girls killed in the 1963 church bombing in Alabama, they were all 14 and younger. The kids who marched in Birmingham's Children's Crusade were beaten and had dogs sicced on them. They were as young as 12. And Emmett Till was 14. He has a memorial in the lynching room, but he wouldn't even be allowed to go down there without a chaperone.
1963年在阿拉巴马州教堂爆炸案中遇难的四个小女孩，她们都只有14岁或更小。在伯明翰“儿童十字军”游行中被殴打并被狗追咬的孩子，年龄最小的只有12岁。而埃米特·提尔当时14岁。他在私刑室里有一个纪念碑，但他本人甚至没有监护人陪同是不能进去的。
Even though the museum upset me, I respect it. It got through to me. Even as an adult watching right-wing pundits discuss the greatness of America, I still think of Mary Turner and her baby. When I left the museum, I had the same feeling I did as a kid, like I was in on a secret about what the country was really like-- like all of America's truths were in a basement on North Avenue.
虽然博物馆让我感到不安，但我尊重它。它触动了我。即使作为成年人，看着右翼评论员讨论美国的伟大，我仍然会想起玛丽·特纳和她的婴儿。当我离开博物馆时，我有种和小时候一样的感觉，好像我掌握了一个关于这个国家真实面貌的秘密——仿佛美国所有的真相都藏在北大道的一个地下室里。
B.A. Parker is one of the producers of our program. Coming up, 40 questions that completely determine a small child's fate. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
B.A.帕克是我们节目的制作人之一。接下来，40个决定小孩子命运的问题。一分钟后，当我们的节目继续时，来自芝加哥公共广播电台。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, Suitable for Children, stories about the random stuff that kids encounter that sticks with them for the rest of their lives, for good or for bad.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目主题是“适合儿童”，讲述孩子们遇到的随机事物，这些事物将伴随他们余生，无论好坏。
We've arrived at Act Three of our program. Act Three, The Questionnaire.
我们来到了我们节目的第三幕。第三幕，问卷。
Of course, the stuff that most affects children is not what they see in museums or what they see on television or what toys they play with. It's the stuff they go through in their lives. Over the last few years, you probably heard there's been a flood of kids who've arrived in the United States by themselves, with no adults at all. Some of these kids are teenagers. Some are a lot younger. How are they going to look back on that experience someday? What's it going to do to them?
当然，对儿童影响最大的不是他们在博物馆里看到的，也不是在电视上看到的，或者他们玩的什么玩具。而是他们在生活中经历的事情。在过去几年里，你可能听说过有大量孩子独自来到美国，根本没有大人陪同。有些孩子是青少年。有些则小得多。有朝一日他们会如何回顾那段经历？那会对他们产生什么影响？
The way it goes once they come to the country, if they turn themselves over to border patrol, they're put into this notoriously cold detention center called the icebox. Then they go to a temporary shelter and they start looking for their parents or relatives in the States to sponsor them. If they find them, they move in with the sponsors, and a few weeks or months later, they'll get a notice to appear in immigration court.
一旦他们来到这个国家，如果他们向边境巡逻队自首，就会被关进一个以寒冷著称的拘留中心，叫“冰柜”。然后他们会去临时收容所，开始寻找在美国的父母或亲属来担保他们。如果找到了担保人，他们就会搬去住，几周或几个月后，他们会收到出庭移民法庭的通知。
So they go to immigration court and then a judge, working with a translator, tells them that they have the right to an attorney, but the government isn't going to pay for an attorney. In other words, it's the kids' responsibility to find and pay for a lawyer or to find a pro bono lawyer. And organizations have sprung up to help with this, but there aren't enough lawyers to go around for all the kids.
于是他们去移民法庭，然后法官在翻译的协助下告诉他们，他们有权请律师，但政府不会支付律师费。换句话说，寻找并支付律师费用或者寻找公益律师是孩子们自己的责任。各组织纷纷成立以提供帮助，但并没有足够的律师能为所有孩子提供服务。
For about a year and a half, Valeria Luiselli observed part of this process firsthand.
大约一年半的时间里，瓦莱里娅·路易塞利亲眼观察了这个过程的一部分。
This is how it starts. It's April 2015 and the boy and I are seated at one end of a long mahogany table. He's 16 years old from Honduras.
事情就是这样开始的。那是2015年4月，男孩和我坐在长长的红木桌子的一端。他来自洪都拉斯，16岁。
I ask him, why did you come to the United States? It's the first question I ask all of the children in immigration court. My task there is a simple one.
我问他，你为什么来美国？这是我问移民法庭里所有孩子的第一句话。我的任务很简单。
I interview children the US government is trying to deport. I ask questions following a questionnaire, and the child answers them. I translate their stories from Spanish into English.
我采访美国政府试图驱逐的儿童。我按照问卷提问，孩子回答。我把他们的故事从西班牙语翻译成英语。
The questionnaire was put together by a coalition of lawyers to help them figure out how to build a case. A case for the child to stay in the country. I'm not a lawyer. I'm just a volunteer.
问卷是由一群律师制定的，旨在帮助他们弄清楚如何构建案件。让孩子留在国内的案件。我不是律师。我只是个志愿者。
I started doing this kind of work when an immigration lawyer mentioned to me that the courts needed interpreters. She was actually my own immigration lawyer. I'm from Mexico. And at the time, I was waiting for my green card to be either granted or denied.
我开始做这类工作是因为一位移民律师提到法庭需要翻译。她实际上是我自己的移民律师。我来自墨西哥。当时，我正在等待我的绿卡是被批准还是被拒绝。
The green card questionnaire is nothing like the intake questionnaire for unaccompanied minors. When you apply for a green card, you have to answer things like, do you intend to practice polygamy? And are you a member of the Communist Party? There's something almost innocent in the green card application's visions of the future and its possible threats.
绿卡申请问卷与无人陪伴未成年人的问卷截然不同。当你申请绿卡时，必须回答诸如：你是否打算实行一夫多妻制？你是否是共产党党员？绿卡申请对未来和潜在威胁的设想中，有一种近乎纯真的东西。
The intake questionnaire for undocumented children, on the other hand, reveals a colder, more cynical and brutal reality. As you make your way down its 40 questions, it's impossible not to feel that the world has become a more [BLEEP] up place than anyone could have ever imagined.
另一方面，无证儿童的问卷揭示了一个更冷酷、更愤世嫉俗且更残酷的现实。当你顺着40个问题往下看时，不可能不感到世界已经变成了一个比任何人所能想象的都要糟糕得多的地方。
The first two questions at the top of the questionnaire are, where is the child's mother? Where is the child's father? The spaces after these questions often remain blank. All the children I interview come without their fathers and without their mothers, and many of them don't even know where their parents are.
问卷顶部的头两个问题是：孩子的母亲在哪里？孩子的父亲在哪里？这些问题后的空格通常保持空白。我采访的所有孩子来时都没有父亲和母亲，他们中许多人甚至不知道父母在哪里。
Question 2, when did you enter the United States? Most children don't know the exact date. They smile and say, last year, or a few months ago, or simply, I don't know.
第2题，你什么时候进入美国的？大多数孩子不知道确切日期。他们微笑着说，去年，或几个月前，或者干脆说，我不知道。
3 and 4, what countries did you pass through? How did you travel here? To the first question, almost everyone immediately answers Mexico, and some also list Guatemala, El Salvador, and Honduras.
第3和第4题，你经过了哪些国家？你是怎么来这里的？对第一个问题，几乎所有人都会立即回答墨西哥，有些人还会列出危地马拉、萨尔瓦多和洪都拉斯。
To the second question, with pride and horror, many say, I came on La Bestia, which literally means The Beast and refers to the freight trains that cross Mexico, on top of which many of these children have ridden. Thousands of people have died or been gravely injured aboard La Bestia, either because of its derailments or by falling off during the night, or by falling into the hands of policemen, thieves, and narcos. But people continue to take the risk because there's no other route to take if you cannot pay.
对第二个问题，许多人带着自豪和恐惧说，我是坐“野兽”号来的，这字面意思是“野兽”，指穿越墨西哥的货运火车，许多孩子都坐在火车顶上。成千上万的人在“野兽”号上丧生或受重伤，要么是因为脱轨，要么是因为在夜间坠落，或者落入警察、小偷和毒枭手中。但人们还是继续冒险，因为如果你付不起钱，就没有别的路可走。
The room where I ask these questions is in a foreboding building at 26 Federal Plaza in downtown Manhattan. Inside, the building branches into hallways, offices, courtrooms, and waiting rooms. There are few signs and few people you can ask for assistance or directions, so it's easy to get lost.
我提问的房间在曼哈顿市中心联邦广场26号的一栋不祥的建筑里。建筑内部延伸出走廊、办公室、法庭和候车室。标志很少，你可以寻求协助或指路的人也很少，所以很容易迷路。
The screening room on the 12th floor has two large mahogany tables at which the children, lawyers, and interpreter sit for the interviews. Crayons and pads of paper are set out at the ends of the tables to entertain the younger kids. I have no control over the type of legal assistance the child will receive. I just listen to their stories in Spanish and note their answers in English.
12楼的放映室有两张大红木桌子，孩子、律师和翻译坐在那里进行采访。桌子末端放着蜡笔和纸板来娱乐较小的孩子。我对孩子将收到的法律援助类型没有任何控制权。我只是用西班牙语听他们的故事，并用英语记录他们的回答。
It's important to record even the most minor details from each story, because a good lawyer can use them to strengthen a case in ways it might not have been evident to an interpreter. She swam across the river. She comes from San Pedro Sula. She comes from Tegucigalpa. She comes from Guatemala City.
记录每个故事中哪怕最细小的细节都很重要，因为好的律师可以利用它们以翻译可能无法明显看出的方式来加强案件。她游泳穿过河流。她来自圣佩德罗苏拉。她来自特古西加尔巴。她来自危地马拉城。
He has not ever met his father. Yes, she has met her mother, but she doesn't remember the last time she saw her. He doesn't know if she abandoned him.
他从没见过父亲。是的，她见过母亲，但不记得最后一次见到她是什么时候。他不知道她是否遗弃了他。
No, my father didn't send money at all. I worked in the fields. MS-13 shot my sister. She died. Yes, my uncle hit me often. No, my grandmother never hit us.
不，我父亲根本没寄过钱。我在田里干活。MS-13枪杀了我的姐姐。她死了。是的，叔叔经常打我。不，祖母从来没打过我们。
If the child answers the questionnaire correctly, he or she is more likely to have a strong case, which will increase the child's chances of being placed with a pro bono attorney. An answer is correct if it provides an attorney with a legal argument for the child to stay in the US. So in the warped world of immigration, a correct answer is when, for example, a girl reveals that her father is an alcoholic who physically or sexually abused her, or when a boy reports that he was beaten repeatedly by gang members and has the scars to prove it.
如果孩子正确地回答了问卷，他或她就更有可能有一个强有力的案件，这将增加孩子被分配给公益律师的机会。如果答案能为律师提供孩子留在美国的法律论据，那么答案就是正确的。因此，在移民的扭曲世界里，正确的答案是，例如，当一个女孩透露她的父亲是一个酒精中毒者并对她进行了身体或性虐待时，或者当一个男孩报告说他被帮派成员多次殴打并有伤疤可以证明时。
Answers like that may open doors to potential immigration relief and eventually legal status in the US. But when children don't have enough battle wounds to show, they may not have any way to successfully defend their case and will most likely be removed back to their home country.
这样的答案可能会为潜在的移民救济和最终在美国的合法身份打开大门。但当孩子没有足够的伤疤可以展示时，他们可能没有任何方法成功为自己的案件辩护，很可能会被遣返回国。
The little girls are five and seven years old, and they're from a small village in Guatemala. We sit together at the mahogany table, and their mother observes from one of the benches in the back. The younger girl concentrates on her coloring book, a crayon in her right hand. The older one has her hands crossed as an adult might. Spanish is their second language. She's a little shy, but tries to be clear and precise in her answers.
小女孩们分别是五岁和七岁，来自危地马拉的一个小村庄。我们一起坐在红木桌旁，她们的母亲在后面的长椅上观察。小女孩专注于她的涂色书，右手拿着一支蜡笔。大女孩像成年人一样交叉着双手。西班牙语是她们的第二语言。她有点害羞，但努力在回答中保持清晰和精确。
Why did you come to the United States? I don't know. Where did you cross the border? I don't know. Texas? Arizona? Yes. Texas, Arizona.
你为什么来美国？我不知道。你在哪里越境的？我不知道。德克萨斯州？亚利桑那州？是的。德克萨斯州，亚利桑那州。
How did you travel here? A man brought us. A coyote? No, a man.
你是怎么来这里的？一个男人带我们来的。蛇头吗？不，是一个男人。
When the younger girl turned two, their mother left them under their grandmother's care. She crossed two national borders without documents and settled in Long Island, where she had a cousin. The girls talk to their mother on the telephone, hearing stories about snow falling and traffic jams, and later, about their mother's new husband and their new baby brother.
当小女孩两岁时，母亲把她们留在祖母照顾下。她越过了两个国家的边界，没有证件，定居在长岛，那里有个表亲。女孩们在电话里和母亲通话，听着关于下雪和交通堵塞的故事，后来，关于她们母亲的新丈夫和新弟弟的故事。
Four years went by. One day, their grandmother told them that, in a few days, a man was going to come for them, a man who would help them get back to their mother. She told them that it would be a long trip, but that he would keep them safe.
四年过去了。有一天，祖母告诉她们，过几天会有一个男人来找她们，一个能帮助她们回到母亲身边的男人。她告诉她们，那会是一段漫长的旅程，但他会保证她们安全。
The day before the girls left, their grandmother sewed a 10-digit telephone number on the collars of their dresses. She told them they should never take these dresses off, not even to sleep, and as soon as they reached America and met the first American policeman, they should show the inside of the dress's collar to him. He would then dial the number and let them speak to their mother. The rest would follow.
女孩们离开的前一天，祖母在她们连衣裙的领子上缝了一个10位数的电话号码。她告诉她们，绝不要脱掉这些衣服，即使睡觉也不要，一旦她们到达美国并见到第一个美国警察，就应该向他展示衣领里面。他就会拨打那个号码，让她们和母亲通话。剩下的事情就会跟着发生。
The rest did follow. They made it to the border and were detained in the icebox. They said they were colder in there than they had ever been. After that, they went to a shelter.
剩下的事情确实发生了。她们到达了边境，并被关在“冰柜”里。她们说那里比她们所感受到的任何时候都要冷。在那之后，她们去了收容所。
And a few weeks later, they were put on a plane and flown to JFK, where their mother, baby brother, and stepfather were waiting for them. Some weeks later, they received the notice to appear. These girls are so young that, in addition to translating from one language to another, I need to reconfigure the questions, shift them from the language of adults to the language of children.
几周后，她们被送上飞机飞往肯尼迪国际机场，母亲、弟弟和继父在那里等候她们。几周后，她们收到了出庭通知。这些女孩太小了，除了进行一种语言到另一种语言的翻译，我还需要重新配置这些问题，将它们从成年人的语言转换成儿童的语言。
27, 28, 29, did you work in your home country? What sort of work did you do? How many hours did you work each day? I reword, interpret.
第27、28、29题，你在家乡工作过吗？你从事什么样的工作？你每天工作多少小时？我重新措辞，翻译。
What kinds of things did you do with your grandmother? We played. But besides playing? Nothing.
你和祖母一起做什么事情？我们玩耍。除了玩耍呢？什么也没有。
Did you work? Yes. What did you do? I don't remember.
你工作过吗？是的。你做了什么？我不记得了。
We go on to questions 30 31, 32, and 33. The older girl answers them while the little one undresses a crayon and scratches its trunk with her fingernail.
我们继续讨论第30、31、32和33题。大女孩回答这些问题，而小的女孩剥掉蜡笔皮，用指甲刮着它的躯干。
Did you ever get in trouble at home when you lived in your home country? No. Were you punished if you did something wrong? No.
你住在国内时在家里遇到过麻烦吗？没有。如果你做错了事会受到惩罚吗？没有。
How often were you punished? Never. Did you or anyone in your family have an illness that required special attention? What?
你受到惩罚的频率是多少？从来没有。你或你的家人是否患有需要特殊照顾的疾病？什么？
The girl's answers aren't really working. They aren't working in their favor, that is. What I need to hear, though I don't want to hear it, was that they had been doing hard labor, labor that put them in danger, that they were being exploited, abused, punished. If their answers don't align with what the law considers reason enough for the right to stay, the only possible ending to their story is going to be a deportation order.
女孩们的回答并没有真正起作用。换句话说，它们对她们的案件没有帮助。虽然我不想听到，但我需要听到的是，她们一直在从事艰苦的劳动，那种让她们陷入危险的劳动，她们受到剥削、虐待、惩罚。如果她们的回答与法律认为的留在国内的理由不符，她们故事的唯一可能的结局将是驱逐令。
The girls are so young that, even if they had a story that secured legal intervention in their favor, they didn't know the words necessary to tell it. For children of that age, telling a story in a second language translated to a third, a round and convincing story that successfully inserts them into legal proceedings working up to their defense, is practically impossible. It's going to be very hard with the answers I'm getting to even find them a lawyer willing to take their case.
女孩们太小了，即使她们有一个能确保法律干预并对她们有利的故事，她们也不知道讲述它所需的词汇。对于那个年龄的孩子来说，用第二语言讲述一个故事并翻译成第三种语言，一个完整且令人信服并成功地将她们插入到为她们辩护的法律程序中的故事，几乎是不可能的。拿着我得到的这些答案，甚至连愿意接手她们案件的律师都很难找到。
The first person I ever asked these questions to was a boy from Honduras, age 16. Let's call him Manu. Why did you come to the United States, I begin. He says nothing and looks at me and shrugs a little. I reassure him. I'm no policewoman. I'm no official anyone. I'm not even a lawyer. I'm also not a gringa, you know. In fact, I can't help you at all.
我问过这些问题的第一个人是个来自洪都拉斯的男孩，16岁。我们叫他马努。你为什么来美国，我开头说。他什么也没说，看着我，耸了耸肩。我安慰他。我不是女警察。我也不是什么官员。我甚至不是律师。而且你知道，我也不是美国佬。事实上，我一点也帮不了你。
So why are you here, then? I'm just here to translate for you. And what are you? I'm a chilanga. I'm a catracho, he says.
那你为什么在这里？我只是来为你翻译的。你是做什么的？我是个墨西哥城人。他说，我是个洪都拉斯人。
So we were enemies. And anyway, he's right. I'm from Mexico City, and he's from Honduras.
所以我们是敌人。不管怎样，他是对的。我来自墨西哥城，他来自洪都拉斯。
Yeah, I say, but only enemies in soccer, and I suck at soccer, anyway, so you've already scored five goals against me. He smiles, perhaps almost laughs. I haven't won his trust, but at least I have his attention.
是的，我说，但在足球上只是敌人，反正我的足球踢得很烂，所以你已经在我身上进了五个球了。他笑了，也许差点笑出声来。我没赢过他的信任，但至少引起了他的注意。
We proceed slowly and hesitantly. Although I try to convey my words neutrally, every question seems to either embarrass or annoy him. He answers in short sentences, sometimes only silent shrugs.
我们缓慢且犹豫地进行着。虽然我试图中立地传达我的话，但每一个问题似乎都让他感到尴尬或恼火。他用短句回答，有时只是沉默的耸肩。
No, he had never met his father. No, he did not live with his mother in his home country. He had met her, yes, but she came and went as she pleased. She liked the streets, perhaps.
不，他从没见过父亲。不，他在家乡没有和母亲住在一起。是的，他见过她，但她随心所欲地来去。也许她喜欢街头。
He doesn't like talking about her. He grew up with his grandmother, but she died a few months ago. His aunt is sitting in the back of the courtroom.
他不愿谈论她。他和祖母一起长大，但她几个月前去世了。他的姑妈坐在法庭后面。
How do you like living with your aunt? He likes her. But even though she's family, he's never really known her. She had always been just a voice inside the telephone.
你喜欢和姑妈住在一起吗？他喜欢她。但即使她是亲人，他从未真正了解她。她一直只是电话里的一个声音。
I got to question 34, the one that often opens Pandora's box but also gives the interviewer the most valuable material for building the minor's case. Did you have trouble with gangs or crime in your home country? Manu pulls a folded piece of paper from his pocket. It's a copy of a police report he filed against gang members who waited for him outside his high school every day. He's held onto the report for years now, guarded it during his journey north like a passport or a talisman.
我问到了第34题，这个问题通常会打开潘多拉魔盒，但也给采访者提供了为未成年人构建案件的最有价值的材料。你在家乡遇到过帮派或犯罪的麻烦吗？马努从口袋里掏出一张折叠的纸。那是他针对每天在他高中外面等他的帮派成员提出的警察报告副本。他多年来一直保留着这份报告，在北上的旅途中像保护护照或护身符一样保护着它。
One day, some boys from the gang Barrio 18 waited outside school for Manu and his best friend. There were too many boys for Manu to fight. He and his friend walked away. The gang members followed.
有一天，一些来自“18街区”帮派的男孩在学校外面等马努和他最好的朋友。男孩太多，马努打不过。他和朋友走开了。帮派成员跟着他们。
Manu and his friend started running. They ran for a block or two until there was a gunshot. Manu turned around, still running, and saw that his friend had fallen. More gunshots followed, but he carried on running.
马努和朋友开始奔跑。他们跑了一两个街区，直到传出一声枪响。马努转过身，边跑边看，发现朋友摔倒了。紧接着又是更多的枪声，但他继续跑。
That night, he called his aunt in New York. They decided he needed to leave the country as soon as possible. He didn't attend his friend's funeral, didn't leave the house until the day the coyotaje arrived at the door.
那天晚上，他给纽约的姑妈打了电话。他们决定他必须尽快离开这个国家。他没有参加朋友的葬礼，直到那个蛇头出现在门口的那天都没有离开过房子。
Question 35. Any problems with the government in your home country? If so, what happened?
第35题。在家乡遇到过政府的麻烦吗？如果有，发生了什么？
My government? Write this down in your notebook. They don't do [BLEEP] for anybody like me. That's the problem.
我的政府？把这写在你的笔记本上。他们对像我这样的人什么都不做。那才是问题所在。
The next time I see Manu some months later, we're in a large room on floor 20-something of a corporate building next to South Ferry. We can see Staten Island from the window and, if we stretch our necks, the Statue of Liberty.
几个月后我再次见到马努时，我们在南渡轮旁边一栋公司大楼20多楼的一个大房间里。我们可以从窗户看到斯塔滕岛，如果我们伸长脖子，还能看到自由女神像。
An organization has found him pro bono lawyers in one of the most powerful and expensive corporate firms in the city. Thanks to the material evidence Manu has of his statements-- the folded slip of paper-- he has a strong case. Stronger than usual, at least. They've called me in to continue translating for him.
一个组织为他找到了城里最强大且昂贵的公司之一的公益律师。多亏了马努所拥有的书面证据——那张折叠的纸条——他有一个强有力的案件。至少比平时强。他们叫我来继续为他翻译。
We sit around a large, black, lacquered table. Manu, his aunt, three lawyers who speak only English, and me. We are offered coffee and snacks. Manu's aunt and I say yes to coffee. Manu says he'll have some of everything if it's free.
我们围坐在一张黑色漆面大桌子旁。马努、他姑妈、三名只会说英语的律师，还有我。我们被提供了咖啡和零食。马努的姑妈和我说了咖啡。马努说如果免费，他什么都要来点。
I translate this into, just a cookie, please. Thanks. That's very kind of you. Everything runs smoothly until the lawyers ask if Manu is still enrolled in school. He is, he says. At Hempstead High School on Long Island, but he wants to leave as soon as possible.
我把它翻译成，请来个曲奇饼。谢谢。你们真是太好了。一切都很顺利，直到律师问马努是否还在上学。他说在。在长岛的亨普斯特德高中，但他想尽快离开。
Why, they want to know. They remind him that, if he wants to be considered for any type of immigration relief, he has to be enrolled in school.
他们想知道为什么。他们提醒他，如果他想考虑任何类型的移民救济，就必须在校学习。
Hempstead High School, he says, is a hub for MS-13 and Barrio 18. Barrio 18 knocked two teeth out of his mouth. He's missing two on the top row. MS-13 boys saved him from losing the rest of them.
他说，亨普斯特德高中是MS-13和18街区帮派的据点。“18街区”帮派把他的两颗牙齿打掉了。他上排缺了两颗。MS-13的男孩救了他，没让他失去剩下的牙齿。
Suddenly, perhaps, we all suspect Manu and want to ask questions 36 and 37. Have you ever been a member of a gang? Any tattoos? No, he has no tattoos. And no, he's never been part of any gang. MS-13 in Hempstead wants him, but he's not going to fall for it.
突然间，也许我们都怀疑马努，想问第36和37题。你曾经是帮派成员吗？有纹身吗？不，他没有纹身。不，他从来没有参加过任何帮派。亨普斯特德的MS-13想要他，但他不会上钩。
Hundreds of thousands of kids have made the journey north. Tens of thousands have made it to the border, thousands to New York. Why did you come to the United States, we ask.
成千上万的孩子踏上了北上的旅程。数万人到达了边境，数千人到了纽约。你为什么来美国，我们问。
These children might ask a similar question. Why did we risk our lives to come to this country, where we find at school, in our new neighborhoods, the very things we are running from? Hempstead is a [BLEEP] hole full of pandilleros, Manu says, full of gang members, just like Tegucigalpa.
这些孩子可能会问类似的问题。为什么我们要冒着生命危险来到这个国家，在这里的学校、我们的新社区中，我们发现了我们正在逃离的东西？亨普斯特德是个帮派成员扎堆的垃圾场，马努说，到处都是帮派成员，就像特古西加尔巴一样。
Valeria Luiselli. This is an excerpt from her book Tell Me How It Ends. She asked that I mention here on the radio that MS-13 and Barrio 18 are gangs that did not originate in Central America or in Mexico. They're originally from Los Angeles.
瓦莱里娅·路易塞利。这是她书《告诉我这一切是如何结束的》的节选。她要求我在广播中提到，MS-13和18街区帮派并非起源于中美洲或墨西哥。它们最初来自洛杉矶。
Act Four, Rocket Boy.
第四幕，火箭男孩。
So we close our show today with somebody who was just a teenager when the army ordered him to report to Camp Desert Rock, which was next to the Atomic Energy Commission's bomb testing range in Nevada in 1955 to do something he was totally unprepared for, though I think maybe nobody could be prepared for. He was 19. His name is Paul Zimmer. He grew up to be a writer and a poet. He wrote this about what happened there. Paul was under the weather this week, so his account was read for us by an actor, John Conlee.
所以我们今天以一个少年的故事结束我们的节目，当时军队命令他在1955年到内华达州原子能委员会的炸弹试验场旁边的沙漠岩营地报到，去做一件他完全没有准备的事情，虽然我认为也许没有人能对此有所准备。他当时19岁。他的名字叫保罗·齐默。他后来成长为一名作家和诗人。他写了关于那里发生的事情。保罗这周身体不适，所以他的叙述由演员约翰·康利为我们朗读。
I'd paid attention. I'd seen the newsreels of Hiroshima, but just watching atomic bombs go off, I thought it was going to be kind of cool. I thought the story would be a way to interest girls.
我曾注意过。我看过广岛的新闻短片，但只是看着原子弹爆炸，我以为那会很酷。我以为这个故事会成为吸引女孩的一种方式。
They didn't tell us anything about what was going to happen, no initiation, no training. And the first time I had no idea what to expect. We travel by convoy and buses in the middle of the night to assemble at the site. We shuffled around in the cold, chain-smoking, till we were ordered into the trenches.
他们没有告诉我们任何关于将要发生的事情，没有入会仪式，没有训练。而第一次，我根本不知道会发生什么。我们半夜乘车队和巴士前往场地集合。我们在寒冷中乱窜，抽着烟，直到被命令进入战壕。
The trenches were long, thin slits in the desert earth, only wide enough for us to line up single file. We wore our steel helmets but were not issued earplugs, eye covers, or any protective clothing. Then they told us to get down.
战壕是沙漠大地上的长而窄的缝隙，只够我们排成单行。我们戴着钢盔，但没有发耳塞、遮眼罩或任何防护服。然后他们告诉我们蹲下。
I did not become fearful until the countdown was broadcast over the loudspeakers. And I only became terrified when I saw the flash, bright enough where, even with my eyes closed, I could see the bones of my hands over my eyes. A shock wave crashed over the trench top and we were ordered to stand up and look. We did and saw the mushroom cloud glowing purple and changing colors, rising, rising up.
直到广播里播出倒计时，我才感到害怕。只有当我看到那闪光时，我才感到惊恐，光亮之大，以至于即使闭上眼睛，我也能看到遮在眼睛上的手骨。冲击波猛烈地撞击在战壕顶部，我们被命令站起来观看。我们照做了，看到蘑菇云发出紫色的光并变换颜色，升起，不断升起。
I saw eight atomic blasts in total all on different days. Some devices dropped from airplanes. And some detonated from towers. There was an aerial burst and an underground blast, as well.
我总共目睹了八次原子弹爆炸，都在不同的日子。有些是从飞机上投下的装置。有些是从塔上引爆的。还有空中爆炸和地下爆炸。
Sometimes during the shock wave, the trench sides caved in and buried us alive, so we had to claw our way out from our own graves. Some poor doggies in Jeeps were assigned to drive forward with Geiger counters and radio transmitters. When clearance was radioed back, we were ordered to walk forward into the blast area to bear witness. Far as I could tell, bearing witness was the entire reason we were there.
有时在冲击波期间，战壕两侧坍塌并把我们活埋，所以我们不得不从自己的坟墓中爬出来。一些带着盖革计数器和无线电发射器的倒霉蛋被指派驱车前进。当清除信号传回时，我们被命令走进爆炸区域去见证。据我所知，见证是我们在那里的全部原因。
The largest bomb I witnessed was called Turk. It was almost three times the size of the Hiroshima bomb. It was dropped from a 500-foot tower, and our trenches were approximately 2 and 1/2 miles from ground zero. The blast yield was bigger than expected so the brass ordered us to retreat to the buses, where we swept each other off with kitchen brooms and hustled into our seats. The next morning, some of us were bussed back into the area in our fatigues and ordered to walk forward to bear witness.
我目睹的最大炸弹被称为“土耳其”。它的威力几乎是广岛炸弹的三倍。它是从一座500英尺高的塔上投下的，我们的战壕距离爆心大约2.5英里。炸弹威力比预期的要大，所以指挥官命令我们撤退到巴士上，我们用厨房扫帚互相打扫身上的尘土，匆忙就坐。第二天早上，我们一些人穿着战斗服被送回该地区，并被命令走上前去见证。
There was still a heavy smell of ozone in the air. Vegetation shredded, scorched, torn out by the roots, and small animals and birds were scattered, dead, crippled, and blind, lurching about, some still trying to find a place to hide. We walked past crumpled vehicles and artillery pieces that had been placed in the open.
空气中仍然有浓重的臭氧味。植被被粉碎、烧焦、连根拔起，小动物和鸟儿四散，有的死掉，有的残废，有的失明，蹒跚而行，有的还在试图找地方躲藏。我们走过被放置在空地上被压扁的车辆和火炮。
Mannequins staked out, khakis torn apart and melted grotesquely. Caged Cheshire pigs that had been dressed in specially-fitting army uniforms were dead or mangled, the latter still shrieking their last. Herds of blasted sheep and cows were mangled together, dead or moaning. Staged houses and barns were splintered and scattered.
摆放的人体模型，卡其布被撕裂和扭曲地融化。关在笼子里的柴郡猪穿着特别定制的军装，已经死亡或受损，后者还在发出最后的尖叫。成群的被炸毁的羊和牛混杂在一起，死的死，呻吟的呻吟。搭建的房屋和谷仓被分裂并散落各处。
We never had to write reports, nor did anyone ask us what we saw because it turned out they were looking at us. They wanted to see how young men reacted to an atomic blast. Apparently, that's all they wanted to do. I was not selected because I was special. I had no need for qualifications, aside from being a 19-year-old boy.
我们从没写过报告，也没人问我们看到了什么，因为事实证明他们是在看着我们。他们想看看年轻人对原子弹爆炸会有什么反应。显然，这就是他们想做的全部。我被选中并不是因为我有什么特别。除了作为一个19岁的男孩，我没有任何资格需求。
Over the years of America's open-air atomic bomb testing in Nevada, a few thousand army men participated. It does not matter anymore that only feeble attempts were made by the government to find out how these experiences affected us. Lately, I've begun to realize that I am one of the last people living in America to have actually experienced close-up explosions of atomic bombs. We're all dying now, and most of us are already dead.
在美国于内华达州进行露天原子弹试验的这些年里，有几千名士兵参与了。政府是否曾费力地试图查明这些经历如何影响我们，这已经不再重要了。最近，我开始意识到我是美国为数不多真正经历过近距离原子弹爆炸的幸存者之一。我们现在都快死光了，大多数人已经死了。
I'm not aware of anyone's health being affected by the blasts, but some years ago I did check with the Veterans Administration about the possible radiation dosage I received during my participation. I was informed that the radiation film badge that I wore throughout my four months at Desert Rock had been burned up in a government warehouse records fire in St. Louis some decades ago.
我不知道有没有人的健康受到爆炸的影响，但几年前我确实向退伍军人管理局询问过我在参与期间可能受到的辐射剂量。我被告知，我在沙漠岩营地四个月期间佩戴的辐射胶片徽章，几十年前在圣路易斯的政府仓库记录火灾中被烧毁了。
Now in my late years, when I can conjure that brief, surreal period of my youth, I try in vain to make some sense of it. In some ways, it has become my responsibility to at least recollect and tell how that great flash and blast permanently reached into my very young mind and heart, how those enormous sounds deadened my ears and still ring in them to this day, how the crush of shock waves sometimes buried us alive in our trenches. I feel it my duty to tell the reckless absurdity of it all.
现在到了晚年，当我能唤起我青春那段短暂而超现实的时期时，我徒劳地试图理解它。在某些方面，至少回忆并讲述那巨大的闪光和爆炸如何永久地触及我年轻的心灵和内心，巨大的声音如何使我的耳朵变聋并至今仍在耳中回响，冲击波的挤压有时如何将我们活埋在战壕里，已经成了我的责任。我觉得我有义务讲述这一切鲁莽的荒谬。
In August, our president threatened to unleash fire and fury like the world has never seen. We keep threatening to unleash these bombs, and so I suspect that one day we will. Most of us have forgotten what we are capable of. I have not.
八月，我们的总统威胁要释放前所未有的火与愤怒。我们一直在威胁要释放这些炸弹，所以我怀疑有一天我们会这样做。我们大多数人已经忘记了我们有能力做什么。我没有忘记。
John Conlee, reading an essay by Paul Zimmer. A version of this essay was first published in The Georgia Review.
约翰·康利朗读了保罗·齐默的文章。这篇文章的版本最初发表在《佐治亚评论》上。
[MUSIC - "KIDS" BY MIKKY EKKO]
[音乐 - MIKKY EKKO的《KIDS》]
Our program was produced today by Jonathan Menjivar. People who put our show together include Susan Burton, Ben Calhoun, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Whitney Dangerfield, Neil Drumming, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Mariya Karimjee, David Kestenbaum, Miki Meek, B.A. Parker, Robyn Semien, Lily Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Nancy Updike, and Diane Wu. Our senior producer is Brian Reed.
我们的节目今天由乔纳森·门吉瓦尔制作。参与我们节目制作的人包括苏珊·伯顿、本·卡尔霍恩、佐伊·蔡斯、达纳·奇维斯、肖恩·科尔、惠特尼·丹杰菲尔德、尼尔·德拉明、斯蒂芬妮·富、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、玛丽亚·卡里姆吉、大卫·克里斯滕鲍姆、米基·米克、B.A.帕克、罗宾·塞米恩、莉莉·沙利文、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼、南希·厄普代克和黛安·吴。我们的资深制作人是布莱恩·里德。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX公共广播交易系统提供给公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, I got a traffic ticket and I said to Torey, hey, gringa, can you represent me in court?
一如既往地感谢节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，我收到了交通罚单，我对托里说，嘿，美国妞，你能代表我出庭吗？
I'm not even a lawyer. I'm also not a gringa, you know.
我甚至不是律师。而且你知道，我也不是美国妞。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。